un nuevo intento de suicidio en el
puente de las américas en la paz este
lugar se ha convertido en un trabajo
frecuente para las autoridades que desde
el inicio de la pandemia en marzo de
2020 no dejan de reportar casos 181
aproximadamente sucesos de todo tipo de
todo tipo de naturaleza en este puente
personas que han sido lanzadas al vacío
que se han precipitado intentos de
suicidio personas que han sido detenidas
por la policía y por particulares
entonces estamos hablando de diferentes
sucesos que han pasado en este puente de
las américas y que esa llama de atención
ha hecho de que la policía nuevamente
implemente el servicio de ciudad de
personal a pie la depresión el aumento
de casos de kobe 19 y las salas de bus y
sin cupo serían los motivos que
llevarían a algunas personas afectadas a
querer quitarse la vida según las
autoridades personas entre los 17 y los
39 años son las que más intentan saltar
al vacío las cámaras de seguridad
alertan a la policía
en el rescate los oficiales han sido
capacitados para evitar más muertes
recordemos la primera vez que les salve
la vida a una persona volvía a recordar
ese sentimiento de sensación que es una
satisfacción que esta persona
[Música]
haya podido ayudar a su casa a dormir a
esa noche la pandemia también ha
contribuido en la profunda crisis
económica que vive bolivia la peor desde
los años 50
cifras oficiales señalan que la pobreza
golpea al 37,5 por ciento de la
población el desempleo un 11% el 62,3
por ciento de los ciudadanos trabajan en
la economía informal